[Musik]
gernot jehovas wird donald trump den
kapitalismus endodontie altmaier
du hast eine sehr sehr gute frage
gestellt wie viele chefs louis sietmann
denn in deutschland nicht allzu viele
vielleicht gar keine richtig aber das
kann ich dir erklären wie ihr deutschen
kaufen kaum ami auch weil die scheiße
wenn du denn jetzt so schnell kommt
twitter dir das noch mal
german cars great annikas beschissen
außerdem darf doch nach us autofirma in
deutschland opel
kennste opel-fahrer stearns spisak peter
visse gehäkelte pro rolle auf der
hutablage mit general motors tochter hat
ihr treiben ich verkauft an die franz
hatten also zu holen und hör auf mit dem
straffen
die machen auch sich produkte in amerika
teurer
kapierst du dich mit strafzöllen wir
verkaufen euch als reine produkte
ausbeutung ist wenn man ein verkappter
telefon mitarbeiter von armen chinesen
war schon wieder zu kompliziert schnell
ich brauche einen schlüsselreiz
verdoppelt
besser also der deutsche
handelsüberschuss ist überhaupt nicht
schlimm wie german bauen einfach geile
sachen du gerade iwf sagt deutschland
muss tatsächlich mehr investieren und
weniger sparen nicht nur damit wie
andere länder weniger verschuldet
sondern um endlich unserer
binnenkonjunktur anzukurbeln klo muss
dringend fried an
[Applaus]